evan welcome back round two
dude so stoked to be here
yes
i love this
house i love your setup
it's a great space
blessed
yeah man 100 blessed
aren't we all absolutely
and then that's
the whole thing
is to recognize oneself as the sun cut
through the clouds
always already the sun
yet it's up to us to recognize it
and when basic needs aren't met it's
harder to
recognize the sun
because of fighting for survival and
safety
and
water and food
and i in the first episode covered a lot
of his trajectory in football and
cannabis and consciousness so in the
second episode we're just gonna dive
right into the essence of the
indescribable perfection that this all
is
bringing
god back to the west
synthesizing science and spirituality
the natural state
versus the altered state
of consciousness
we can give a little bit of context
there that the altered state being the
state of separation the state of ego
and then the natural state being the
state of oneness being the state of
infinity being the state of nothingness
being the state of perfection
so
eb i would really like for you to share
since december since our first episode
what have been these pivotal pivotal
cutting through the clouds to recognize
the sun for you
and what insights has that yielded
[Laughter]
what
what does a miracle look like
like what does a miracle look like
we are
constantly
in the west in particular which is why i
brought that up to you
in our text yesterday
bringing the west back to god
and at first i was going to say how do
we bring god back to the west but god is
already here he's been here
and it seems as though
the west has done its damnedest at
extricating itself from
oneness
the universe the universal reality of
god of
truth
and we're really looking for something
to be that miracle
that experience
that's why
psychedelics are so powerful and have
emerged the way they have in the last
few years and especially
because they give us that explosion
into the oneness into
that natural state of consciousness and
i love what you said
because at first
someone might
say altered altered states of
consciousness versus the natural state
of consciousness oh the altered state is
when you're on psychedelics or on some
sort of
drug drug-induced trip in the natural
state that's
that's me that's where i am you know and
i love how you redefined it and flipped
it on its head
um
and
we are so desperate for answers we are
so desperate to concretize
our environment our reality and say this
is this and this is this and
this is how it is
never once
stopping to
be with what actually is
and i don't know how to describe
the difference between who i was
seven months ago or eight months ago
when i was here last the person sitting
here today likewise
and even then back then i would have
said
i'm a different person than i was six
months ago
um
and it really comes down to this
constant surrendering to
what is
letting go
of the thoughts letting go of the
thinking letting go of the figuring out
letting go of the
trying
and just feeling what is
it speaks volumes over the thought
chatter
that comes you know
it just speaks volumes
and i posted this thing the other day
buddha said
when i speak i compromise myself
love that post
and
it's so true
you know we were talking earlier before
when i got here
the gateless gate
the
fearless van the veilless veil
the chain list the chainless chains so
good so good and then i was thinking as
we sat down the podcastless podcast how
do you do a podcast without words
just like the silence the energy
reverberate through the microphones and
let that
bless the ears of whoever's
brave enough to listen
but it's because words are so
limited
and words
our mind our minds
use words to create
they come into our minds we hear the
sounds come into our minds and they're
symbols
and our minds use these words to create
a construct a model of understanding so
that we can then
process the information that's coming in
and receive it and make an idea or
create a concept around what it is
that's being spoken about
all the while losing perhaps complete
touch with
the energetic
meaning
that was intended
from the speaker or whatever it might be
all the while
throughout society we've really gotten
ourselves into this place where
we are so righteously
trying to do good
and trying to do the right thing
and trying to make everyone comfortable
and meanwhile it's creating more
division it's creating more separation
more isolation
and
that's really what buddha was talking
about you know he could have the golden
nugget of wisdom
the golden ticket of the thing that he
could give to his students and say
listen to this read these words hear
what hear what i have to say to you and
they could still receive it in any
[ __ ] way
that was possible that could totally be
contradictory or tangential or whatever
it might be in terms of what he was
actually trying to impart on his
students
and so it's difficult
to describe yeah
yeah this coming to oneness yeah
yep or this coming to the realization of
there's nothing to figure out there's
nothing to understand yeah
and this isn't
this isn't some kind of
you know i wrote this whole piece about
it
i wrote this whole piece about it
why in the west we're so fascinated by
the eastern mystics and the gurus
and
audiences sit completely spellbound
someone like saad guru or osho or ramdas
or whoever it might be
audiences it's spellbound american
people spellbound vivekananda came in
the 1890s to america to bring yogic
philosophy
to this country
because his master his his teacher
saint uh
ramakrishna
told him
vivekananda this is your work you have
to go and impart this wisdom these
teachings onto the world so he went to
america
and it was fascinating to me because i
just did a podcast about this that yoga
came to america first
in its psychology
in its spirit it didn't come as the
physical
art form that we know
know it as today which has become
predominant and i think there's great
value in the physical art form of it
totally absolutely in the asana practice
of yoga
but he came and he blew people's minds
talking about oneness talking about
the greater good the truth of who we all
are as beings underneath all of this
stuff yes
and it occurred to me that
you know audiences american audiences or
western audiences we sit spellbound in
the midst of these gurus
because
with such clarity
and such depth and such non-attachment
is really the key yeah
yeah they are non-attached not fixated
and they can muse
on the mechanisms of the human mind and
the human experience yes
and so audiences sit transfixed
in the in the
environment in the atmosphere of this
non-attached being
and
all of us have if you've ever had the
chance to sit with someone like that
you have that experience of
being immersed in their
bliss
in their state of consciousness
only
to five minutes after you walk out of
the place
you're sucked right back into your
dualistic
paradigm
of me and i and you or you and that's
them and
i have my beliefs and wow how about that
guy he really knew some things didn't he
and the guru
goes back to doing his thing laughing
the whole way understanding this because
he realizes he knows that every single
person every individual in that audience
has the capability to
experience or live in that state of
awareness
yeah
but is simply trapped in this way of
thinking or way of believing things are
yeah
as a result of being attached and being
fixated on the things
and so
there are
i don't know if this makes sense is it
making sense yeah it seems like
we're
diving
into
the indescribable perfection also from a
mysticism
and a western which is
very insightful and helpful and also the
core essence of the
buddhist and generally eastern
teachings and i would like to
also
tie in
a thread here that will be important to
weave which is what exactly is the
mystic or the yogi um bringing with them
um
and you mentioned this several times
this non-attachment this non-fixation
this density of consciousness light
love
that is
in union with oneness in union with
nothing in infinity
in union with
serving the field
in a way that is not attached but hyper
compassionate because it sees the field
as itself
and
so
the
the core
suchness the core union that the mystic
or the yogi is in
is both what we already are and yet it
is also
a
a cessation of the fluctuations of mind
that enable us to actually
feel the essence
of the one heart that underlies
everything
and that has always underlied everything
and that will always underlie everything
and so the the tying thread
it really just it really does feel like
the the self-inquiry question of who am
i or what is this i
me my
is this first link in this dependent
origination
is
am i attached to this appearance of a
costume in the game of life
or am i aware that what underlies the
costume is that essence of sachitananda
existence consciousness bliss
that oneness and that unity because as
soon as you venture into mind and
separation and likes and dislikes and
indifferences in samsara
that is
directly related to your attachment to
identity so it's it's really yeah the
link goes from oneness
from absolute equanimity absolute
suchness
to
the first is
the distortion of identity is the first
link with ignorance
and then it's with that i me my and
attachment to costume is likes dislikes
and differences in samsara
and so it really is that cutting through
clouds to an abiding awakening presence
so that's a little knit through what
where
i love that i love that dude cool
um so good
no that's awesome
and in that
coming back to what does a miracle look
like yeah what
what is that thing that you're
constantly seeking that you think is
going to bring you the answer
you know
that so many people are trapped in
and
when you get on the
this fast track of evolution of your
consciousness where you really start to
experience these things
that presents traps in itself because
then you're looking for that
god experience once again as the thing
that's going to show you that you're on
the path still or whatever it is you
know
and uh
for me it's been a
a big part of my process has been a
letting go of that
yeah letting go of
the
the seeking out of the bliss the seeking
out of the oneness the seeking out of
the
whatever it is that i think is the thing
that denotes that i'm
on the spiritual path yeah
because what's what about all that stuff
in between there
from one miracle to the next what about
all of that
it's not like god stopped happening
or that the universe stopped happening
what about when i'm not feeling so
intensely connected
and so intensely
inspired and creative what about that
because that's [ __ ] that's real too
that's [ __ ] there that's all of it
happening too yes
the ebbs and the flows yes
rom das
one of my favorite he's one of my
you know i listen to these guys all the
time
because it keeps me
it keeps my eye on the ball
listening to guys like rom das or osho
in particular alan watts
because the way they speak about the
reality
or the universal reality or the nature
of reality
i find it brings me back to shedding the
spiritual
materialistic [ __ ]
the ramnas talks about something that
was so profound to me and i think many
in the west who are venturing onto this
path whether it's through meditation or
yoga or psychedelics even
and you
he said when he first started meditating
he was working with this guy joseph
goldstein he's a master meditation
teacher
and he
he's working with joseph and he's at
this like you know week-long meditation
retreat
and he's in there meditating
and he said he was just experiencing
such bliss and such peace and just it
was so rich and his life was just
expanding beyond anything he could have
ever imagined
and he said he got up from the
meditation and he walked over to joseph
and he said
joseph i just
i can't thank you enough man i can't
thank you enough i've never felt
so blissful
and beautiful and at peace in my entire
life
and joseph said that's great man just go
back sit down and keep listening to your
breath
you know
and he realized he was like oh [ __ ]
because then of course inevitably
throughout that week-long meditation
retreat he was going to experience
mind-boggling boredom you know
mind-boggling
you know discontent impatience all of
these things frustration
and he said the realization he had was
that any time i'm caught in the seeking
of the peace or the bliss or the
richness
i'm still
i'm attached i'm hooked in this
dualistic paradigm
because with the piece there's chaos
that's the flip side to the coin with
the bliss or the the pleasure there's
pain on the other side of that there's
suffering on the other side of that
and so
to take that to the next level he talks
about the saints in india
and in india they call these people the
living dead
because these guys are living in that
space of nothingness
and they don't teach they barely speak
they just be their life is their
teaching
in this place and he says that they're
bearing the unbearable
which is this sensation or this place of
existence where you're
you're living in the place of
complete non-attachment to anything
you're completely
detached from the experiential ebbs and
flows yes
now that doesn't really do us a whole
lot of good if we're trying to have a
podcast
you know
if we're
playing the role of the husband the
father
the teacher
[Music]
so what do we do with that what can we
do with that
in the west and bringing
the west back to god which is why i love
what you do so much dude because you
you
are coming at this thing from a place
that is
highly relatable to
a
consciousness or a model of
consciousness
that is
perhaps
unwilling to go to these places
yep because it really is as simple as
the deconstructing of the self yes
it's that simple it is there's no
yeah
you know the students come to the zen
master
the zen masters give them or any
spiritual guru they give them these
koans
these unanswerable questions
or there's another great story
i can't remember who it is
but
one of the great
spiritual mystics
he found his teacher
either in india or china or whatever it
was japan
and
the teacher
said
okay i need you to go over there and
build build a house
and the student run okay i went and
built the house went and got the one got
his master and he said look man i built
the house
teacher goes
tear down
tear it all down yeah it's just
intense
he's like
uh
okay
so he goes he tears it all down
he goes back gets his master and brings
it he's like look man i tore down the
house it's like build it up again
and he's like
okay
there he goes he builds it up again
goes and gets his master look i did it i
built it up again master goes [ __ ]
tear it down
and it was
it was just the complete deconstruction
of this guy's
psychological prism of thinking that
spirituality was going to come through
any vessel vehicle teaching
[ __ ] magic pill whatever it is
enlightenment was not that
because we have to get out of our way we
have to get out of the [ __ ] way
because it's all there it's all
happening right there right now right
here
you know
do you do you feel like it would be
valuable for us to
explore the process of deconstructing
ourselves
yes
i love that because if we're aiming to
synthesize spirituality into science and
entrepreneurship and
the individualism of the west
that
one of the
core ways to do it is
to have the west in its
obsession with form and name yeah and
differentiation to go through a process
of
deconstructing
the
very nature of their identity itself
just go direct to the source or to the
heart
so
when normally i like
asking
the question
what is looking
and for those that are really sincere
because if there's a high level of
sincerity there'll be a high level of
humility and a high level of earnest
inquiry
rather than this
conditioned response
and so the suggestion might be something
like
might it be
god
or nothing or infinity
oneness
perfection itself eternity looking at
itself might this be eternity talking to
itself
using the costumes of
eben and atlas
to talk to itself in an exploration
called life universe
and so
the simple
shift in deconstructing identity is from
the
separate self
to recognizing oneself as the very
source
of it all
playing with itself
and therefore
the only
expression
that emerges from that state of
compassion is service
honorable loving compassionate
service so what kind of a process are
you using with the deconstructing of
self and where their resonance is there
you know for me it all begins with the
breath
beautiful
because
the breath is
the
is is the tool we have access to
to
in which we are able to tap into our
nervous system
and to switch
from
the low vibrational frequency of our
reptilian brain fight flight freeze
which many of us are walking around in a
low hum state of that
awareness constantly
which is a direct result of constant
mouth breathing
and very high chest and neck breathing
and it switches us when we activate
through nasal breathing we activate our
parasympathetic nervous state
which is our rest digest recover
nervous state but it's also
it activates our prefrontal cortex the
godhead
so human beings we're so
we are such a miracle manifestation of
the universe because we are animal and
god combined we have the animal
instincts this animal
body
that can hunt and run and jump and do
all these things necessary for survival
but we have been gifted with god
consciousness
this infinite eternal consciousness
memory
imagination
so
with that
now we've also
through the prism of our
what can we call that our
the matrix of our being
being birthed into this physical realm
into the body that we're given
or that we chose depending on
your perception
or your understanding or your
belief system
with family
friends
an ecosystem of
people
around us other organisms other divinely
constructed organisms
that then go to create this
psychological
spiritual
prism of
awareness understanding
traumas
experiences that then when we become
adults
everything is functioning through or
coming through this prism
is that making sense yeah as though
there's this
the awareness itself
um is like the black hole at the center
of the galaxy and all of the
family friends concepts ideas name
career
form separation all of those things are
the star systems and planets that are
orbiting around this black hole and
we're wondering what happens when you
turn
the what happens when you turn awareness
on itself what happens when you
investigate the very black hole the very
awareness love light yes
all of that
that's not really uh uh
that
i'm i'm
giving all of this as context to where
we're going to how you get into
unraveling yourself
so the breath
helps us tap in helps us clear the mind
it helps us
let go of at least momentarily without
having done the significant work
whether that's through psychotherapy or
psychedelics or
various healing modalities etc bodywork
yoga
you can momentarily let go of the
clutter and the things that are sort of
lingering in your psychic ether
so then
take a deep breath
into the solar plexus
in through the nose
use your diaphragm to pull that air in
you can just let it all out
and let it out the mouth
let that exhale take with it all the
tension in your body
take another breath in the nose
into the solar plexus
yeah
i just let it all out let it all out
immediately you feel this
sense of
relief
you feel a sense of
betterness
and so when you practice this and you
cultivate this practice throughout your
life and this is all day every day this
is coming into awareness of your being
now when things start to come up
anger
frustration sadness
grief
old memories emerge that's why the asana
practice of yoga to me is so powerful
because this body this physical vessel
things get stored in it
traumas experiences they get stored in
all these places in our body
so there are four planes
of existence spiritual plane emotional
plane
mental plane physical plane these
correlate to the four elements spiritual
to fire
emotional the water
mental to air physical to earth
now when you
begin to use these and all these planes
function independently but also
interdependently with one another
the universe is all built on the
emotional body
our emotional body is what the universe
responds to so when you're talking about
manifestation this is about emotional
body level beliefs
you could also rename the emotional body
as the subconscious
so
your subconscious or your emotional body
functions on a level
of belief
based on past
premises
through past experiences so now your
perception of your
current reality
is a projection of your emotional body
belief about who you are what you are
the world around you what's safe what's
not your level of success what's
possible what's impossible
so
now the beauty of this is that our
subconscious mind or our emotional body
is amenable
it's suggestible we can reprogram it we
can redefine the belief system
of
what we believe is possible and our
perception of our reality
how do you do that you do that through
the physical plane you do that through
the earthly plane
you do that by getting into action you
do that by
little by little step by step taking
actions
which show your emotional
body programming it with new input with
new
beliefs about what is possible and how
that possibility comes into fruition
so
for instance an old programming thing
might be anger comes up that anger gets
expressed in a number of ways in a fight
and an argument and a
verbal
altercation
maybe if you've done some work you
express it through exercise or through
artwork or through some other expression
some others formal form of work
but now once you've retrained that even
and you've developed this sense of
non-attachment to it through the breath
the breath and meditation are the keys
in my opinion or in my experience
of developing
non-attachment developing
or releasing yourself from the
attachment to these things that we cling
to as being ours or mine
what buddha called annapanasati um
love that yeah so we have this
deep
use of this tool that is forever with us
of the inhalation and exhalation very
deep mindfulness
which then gives us the right view of
the nature of reality perpetually yes
i had a head coach in the nfl
coaches had a lot of great things to say
i don't know if they believed them all
or you put them into use but
one of the best things mark tressman
head coach of the chicago bears while i
was there
he said guys
if you ever find yourself in a situation
or a place where you think you might not
be sh maybe you shouldn't be here maybe
it's not a good thing that you're here
take three deep breaths
and then make a decision
i was like yeah [ __ ] yeah dude yeah
and um
so
so now you get to this place where okay
anger comes up oh
that's not mine
let's look under the blanket
of anger who's under there
who's under there
oh that's the little kid oh that's the
teenager who is always insecure
who thought he was never good enough
oh that's the little kid
who was scared because he was growing up
in a chaotic household ah
i see you in sight
i love you yes i'm with you
we're safe now yes
perfect
i'm currently reading this book letting
go david hawkins pathway of surrender
and he talks about how our emotions and
see this is what's so powerful about
emotions emotions are the amalgamation
of thousands of thoughts and experiences
that we've had throughout our lifetime
and they culminate in these emotions now
in the west are really [ __ ] bad
at allowing our emotions
we believe that it's not okay to feel
things
somehow i don't really understand how
that
became so ingrained in our belief system
some woke
ideologue might say that i had something
to do with toxic masculinity or some
nonsense like that but i just don't
i don't see any connection to that
although
men in particular are in a spiritual
crisis
because of this old paradigm of what
true masculinity is supposed to be or
what it's supposed to look like but
that's another conversation but
overarching in the west we have such a
difficult time allowing our emotions so
what do we do we suppress them we
repress them
we express them unconsciously
we escape
we go into our phone we go to the porno
we go to the thing we go to the video
game whatever it might be we do whatever
we can
to shift
our perception out of the feeling
the
the issue is those feelings they don't
just go away
they get suppressed
and they get buried and they build up a
karmic weight
around them
an energetic weight
that gets compacted and compiled and it
grows and it becomes bigger and more
volatile and then at some point it has
to be expressed
volcanic eruptions exactly we see this
all the time
see it all the
time and it's a direct result of the
suppressing
and repressing of emotions over entire
lifetimes people are having [ __ ]
heart attacks all over the world because
of this
cancer all of these things
so what do we do with that what do we do
how do we get to the place
where the emotions can come up
and be beautiful and be celebrated
like fireworks yes and also
having equanimity yes so rather than
being
shifted into
the vicissitudes of pleasure and pain
incessantly
having equanimity with this radical
allowing and loving yes
because that
my brother
is where the miracles happen
this is the [ __ ] miracle yes
experiencing the thing
without having to go somewhere because
there's nowhere to go anyway there's
nowhere to go anywhere just right here
right now
what is it that
is the juicy gem in the field where no
one wants to look yes
and how do we lovingly
hold space for that gem
to be lovingly played with and danced
transmuted
into a higher density of light of
consciousness
and you don't even have to do anything
that's what you realize
like even the thing of looking under the
blanket
eventually you go
there's no blanket
what about this anger what about this
thing
what about the boredom
it's an appearance oh
and then you're just in it you allow it
and then all of a sudden it just
blooms into everything
and you're more rich you're more
to see it as an
appearance and to see it not
appearing to an identity yes just as an
appearance as a manifestation of
infinite potential
without any identity yeah there's no
little
no little atlas experiencing the
anger yes but rather just an appearance
of infinite potential appearing as anger
and then having this level of love and
equanimity in the appearance
and no resistance absolute
non-resistance
or fear you know fear i use anger a lot
because anger is something that comes up
for me but fear
so many people are experiencing fear
and the fearlessness is exactly what
enables us to look at the places that
we all
struggle with looking at
yes um
[Music]
yeah that's so powerful that's so
powerful and just to wind that back a
little bit
because
as you're on this
evolutionary path evolution of
consciousness call it
the pathless path yeah yeah
as you're on that and you find yourself
going hey man
i've got it [ __ ] figured out i'm a
pretty spiritual dude
i'm a spiritual contest frankie says
yeah
they're the trap is
now yes such a trap of the spiritual
path is that all of a sudden you're
feeling the things and you're going whoa
man whoa
i'm spiritual i can't be angry
i can't be sad i can't be [ __ ] scared
i'm spiritual man i'm waiting
you're way too spiritual to feel that
that's when you know
the ego has stepped back in
i should be much more oneness uh
wait wait man
but then all of a sudden you go wait
no that is the thing yes
exactly that's exact catalyst that is
needed right now
it's the exact appearance that is needed
right now that is appearing right now
that's the thing yes [ __ ] yes
perfect divine appearance for exactly
that pathless path of evolution
indescribable
indescribable
perfection
how do we get somebody what is the thing
is there a thing
like we were talking how do we create an
app
how do you put dmt into an app
two things i want to say about this
reality is energy doing work
i had a dream
i had a dream
four or five months ago
it was indescribable perfection
there was no ebbin
it was complete nothingness and it was
bliss and it was everything
it was nothing and it was everything yep
and i was thinking about it i've thought
about it a handful of times i've had a
handful of
absolutely
hard exploding your dreams your dream
into an into that yeah yeah yeah
and i thought to myself oh if i hadn't
been
such a
heavy meditator on this path this could
have been a terrifying experience
yeah yes
this could have been a completely
terrifying experience
but it was so blissful
there was it was the oh it was ocean it
was [ __ ] universal
it was i i was everything and nothing
yes yes
coming back to buddha when i speak i
compromise myself because the words
nothingness and everything how do we cut
how do we rectify this how do we
oh
yeah
there's another dream i want to tell you
about yes
in this dream i woke up on this
spaceship
and it was it looked
like so far it doesn't sound like a
dream
wait till the end bro
you're gonna realize it's not a dream
i woke up on this spaceship and it
looked like the
xenomorph
from alien
organic black skin on everything was the
spaceship
and i was with this group of people
and we were all in these
we were all in these xenomorphic space
suits
and we had all just woken up and were
sort of wandering around the ship trying
to figure out we know we have a mission
and we know we're going somewhere
but we don't know
what it is we're doing or where it is
we're going
and we're calling in on the on the on
the
like panel the command center we're
calling into hq trying to get the
answers and up on the screen is this
screen that has us just careening
through space so we could see the
outside of the ship we're going
somewhere
no one from hq is responding can't get
anything
not getting any answers right where are
we going there was no fear it was just
like
okay yeah cool like we're figuring this
out we're good
seeing
space just flying by stardust is just
whipping by
like if you've ever been in a car at
night and it's black in front of you
and it's either snowing or misty and you
just see the particles just flying
through the blackness that's what it was
like
all of a sudden this voice comes on
and it says
there is no mission
there is nowhere to go
you are inside
an intergalactic being
and you are a particle
of this being
and all of a sudden it like blasted out
of the ship my perception blasted out of
the ship and i just saw us as a particle
in this gigantic being's foot going
somewhere
and i had the egoic moment of going oh
man like there is nothing to do
there is nowhere to go
but then i just completely surrendered
into it
i was like oh
yeah that's life
like we're always searching for the
mission we're searching for the [ __ ]
destination
but it's like we're here
already yes
yes
and just like a particle
a cell in your heart or a cell in your
brain or a cell in your bones
that cell has no [ __ ] idea where
you're going or what you think you're
doing
all it's doing is being the best heart
cell the best bone cell the best brain
cell it can possibly be
the 30 trillion cell and body analogy to
the 8 billion person analogy on the
planet to the
billions of planets in the universe
analogy yeah
it's like so often at least for me in my
experience i want to know like where are
we going what's this about
those have been big questions for me in
my life
well
and they dissolve into the mystery yeah
and then all of a sudden it's like oh
first of all
well one of my great mentors says to me
all the time he says
ed we're on a need to know basis
and right now you don't need to know
yeah and you know frankly as far as like
where we're going or what this is all
about that's none of your [ __ ]
business yeah because you're
a heart you're a heart cell
yeah and a flower does not
ask a question about why it what's it
purpose is exactly the aroma is
beautiful exactly so that gets us back
to another
question
questions give us more questions
so then how do we all tap into our
purpose
how do we all tap into our heart
cellness
what is our divine purpose
and it may look shades they're shades of
it it may look a little different for
everybody yeah
what was coming up was abundance
abundance prosperity i love that dude
play how was that coming up through
really the heart god did guiding heart
just yeah
just and also the feeling of the
connectedness that
avalokiteshvara connectedness of the
bodhisattva encompassing all buddhas
that that style of
just the essence of what it looks like
of pure abundance and pure prosperity
pure play
in whatever expression it takes on right
yeah
being of service
to the organism
the grand symphony
of it all
being of service to it
from a place that's empty of self from a
place that's empty of unworthiness or
the need for validation right
yeah yes yep
that's that's the key and and the way to
and evan has been pointing at this
several times but
to
do the self inquiry to do the
to do the recognition that
when there is
the i me or my
that seems to arise
to discard it as
discard it
discard the like dislike indifference
discard the i me my perpetually netty
netty not this not that over and over
and over again until you are just
truly empty of self until you are just
truly empty of conditioning
and then the service
becomes effortless yes lao tza talked
about way
this is just an effortless action that's
spontaneous and playful and in pure
service that's empty of self yes
yes
out of nothing comes everything yeah
so reality is energy doing work
yeah and to be really comfortable with
being nothing to be really comfortable
with being energy energy energy is not a
thing it is no thing
this is what's right this is what's
really important light
electromagnetism is not a thing this
oxygen
that is being inhaled
it's no thing it's not a thing that's
why we habitually overlook it
consciousness is not a thing it's no
thing awareness is no thing
the nature of mind is not a thing it's
empty cognizance suffused with awareness
there's not a thing when you look and so
when you look you recognize my nature
you recognize essence
you recognize no thing
and then from there
it is so much easier to empty self so
much easier to empty conditioning so
much easier to see the arising and
passing of a thought or emotion or
belief or experience or perception
sensation
this whole new level of sovereignty and
will and power and choice and oneness
and love
that emanates into the field in pure
service and honor
and to understand that when you when you
take in this
it really does start intellectual in
many ways right it starts off
intellectual which is so beautiful
because you can use this beautiful
intellect to gather concepts gather
ideas
and you know
the idea of oneness can be understood
from an intellectual way
with physicalism in the sense of well
yeah i guess technically i take these 20
000 inhales a day and it comes from
phytoplankton and trees
and so there's this indescribable
interdependency of oneness that's
happening
right
and so you start intellectually and then
over time the mind empties as it becomes
more silent and you drop your awareness
into your heart
and gut
and then it's just it becomes visceral
oneness moment to moment yes yes and so
it's cool like use the intellect to go
beyond the intellect absolutely yeah
absolutely
i had an experience once
where
it was actually when i was still working
with mike
and i had no idea what the thing was
but i
i was
doing something
with another guy who worked there like i
was bringing him something so that he
could complete this thing
and i had such a powerful
crystallization
of this
experience where
literally as i was making the handoff of
this thing to him
i had this full
experience of
there was no us
and it was the universe
coming together
to make this thing happen perfect
i love it just during day time yeah yeah
it was normal
like there was no me there was no him it
was a it was a connection of the
universe
particles in the universe came together
to do this thing yes yes it's great
we went to see the big lebowski
uh this past weekend at the hollywood
forever cemetery it was amazing so fun
i'm watching this movie it's one it's
probably my favorite movie of all time
and i've always thought it's such a
it's a fairy tale it's like a it's it's
mythology it's got a biblical essence to
it
it's spiritual allegory
and it really hit me
after watching it this weekend what it
truly was that strikes me about the
movie
and it's that you have this character
the dude
who is essentially
a nobody
because you have no idea where he comes
from you have no real idea of like
who he is
you're just dropped in on this character
this nobody
who becomes everything to everybody
it was like
that's it dude that's the genius of this
film yeah
and you see that now after
more and more your density of light
consciousness
increasing you're able to
see at a at a new
depth yeah that insight yeah because you
watch it five years ago ten years ago no
insight i'm like there's something this
movie is so you know it's hilarious it's
beaut it's a masterpiece of the film
if you've never seen it i highly
recommend it and let's just bring this
analogy directly into your life what are
you
before your parents are born right
nobody nobody no body no body
literally and then an egg meets a sperm
and out of nothing
comes everything comes everything yeah a
single cell abiogenesis somehow turns
into 10 million
species on the planet simultaneously
interdependently
playing with themselves dancing making a
symphony called life
and you are all of it and none of it and
that's the beauty of it and just
the intellectual if it's if it's
intellectual play with it intellectually
for now yeah and then it becomes more
and more
experiential
and then it becomes realized
[Music]
and then it's playing from there yeah
there are many paths to the top of the
flat mountain
it's so good yeah exactly this this
it's a perfect way to summarize
the essence of the nature because it has
to be
simultaneity it has to be
it has to be both so whenever
it's paradox whenever you see it written
as just non-duality it's missing duality
right whenever it's written as just
duality it's missing under when it's
written as just individualism it's
missing oneness or nonduality
so
the equation
looks something like the integral of
everything
the summation of everything yes
and so
it's flat
because there's nothing to do you're
already it right non-duality yeah
and yet there's also the appearance of a
dualism where there is some sort of a
cloud of separation that people feel
like a contracted energy that then
apparently goes through a process of
seeking and cutting through some sort of
clouds that then apparently feels
liberated and at one again yeah and so
that's this like flat mountain idea or
this veilus veil gateless gate shameless
chains escape-less escape room
there's so many of these ways to put it
into a simultaneity yes
well really you know
i love when i hear you talk about this
stuff because my whole system is going
through this integration
you too with this whole episode it's
been so nice yeah dude
the biggest issue is that we think it's
supposed to
feel or look like something else
yeah
you think oh when i'm enlightened it
should feel like or it should look like
everything is one
but what
that's
you
it's so weird it really is weird because
10 years ago there was so much more
mind fluctuation
and that's what veiled
the oneness that's what
um
create that's what created a seeker
separation separation created a seeker
and
then
that contracted energy
totally underwent some sort of an
apparent apparent process of liberation
and and recognizing its boundlessness
its freedom
and so that this so this is the
simultaneity whenever you hear a
non-dual teacher telling people that
come to their meetings that there's
nothing to do
um
you just you gotta also
recognize both the simultaneity there
that's so so crucial well think about it
and you described it as a limbic
neuroscientific infrastructure and a
prefrontal neuroscientific
infrastructure yes
and why is there
an anapanasati
what do these things
truly yield what fruits do they yield
where when you used to be reactive
and then you
went through some sort of an apparent
process
of creating a
gap where you no longer react right away
what did that space actually create
because is there a difference there is
an apparent difference
yes
how are you going to describe it
no no
it's all
to me it always comes back to the
letting go
of the expectation or the perception of
it should be something else because this
is it yeah you know and
if you think about it as we were birthed
into this
dual
paradigm
into our individuality
out of the oneness
we are the oneness coming into this
individual form
in the physical plane
so we are born with this inherent
seeking of how did wait
we were one now we're
disconnected but we're not disconnected
yeah that's a cool way to put it too yep
you were simply the oneness having an
experience of itself yeah
alan watts said something i
this has caught my ear a handful of
times lately and i don't think i ever
tuned into it but
he talks about how
flowers and bees are truly one organism
yeah
because the bees
carry the pollen
from the flowers that they collect
nectar out of spread the pollen and
create more flowers and they're
interdependent on one another
and it's really truly one organism the
bees and the flowers we created a
separation right
just because we look at it and it
doesn't look like they're the same
organism
we just decided oh that's bees and those
are flowers and they're different things
but they're truly one thing
that functions
interdependently
and we are truly that with everything
yes
you know part of the deal is we think
we're not good enough
we're always trapped and we're not good
enough or we don't deserve it or
we can't possibly be that magnificent
yeah yeah yeah that's an interesting one
you know isn't it that's a yeah
i can't possibly be pure potentiality
yeah i can't possibly do all that
really give it a try [ __ ] around man see
what's up
that's truly the blessing of my life i
would say is that i was blessed
with people
around me who always
for better or worse
infuse me with the belief that nothing
is impossible
in the boundlessness
of my being
and of course we come into things you
know
the educational indoctrination system
government
marketing ads
pharmaceutical companies all this [ __ ]
it tells you you need x y and z to be
whole
and slowly but surely you're like wait i
don't
i can't be good enough if i don't have
the cars and the house and the pills and
the girls and the
stuff and the
the gucci belt and the
louis vuitton i can't
i'm not good enough
just letting all of that go
i love that
again just
going back to before your parents were
born and bringing that essence
of who you were before your parents were
born to
now
while you're alive yeah and can you be
nothing
can you be comfortable
with being nothing and what does that
mean
to me that means you are present with
everything yes
yes because you're not locked into some
identity ego trip and whole yes yeah
whole yeah identity ego trip exactly
yeah
unwholeness makes identity ego trip
yes
or the perception of unwholeness the
perception of one wholeness exactly
because
you're the sun and the sun cannot go out
and look for more light to be added to
it
this the cup when the cup is full it
cannot receive more water into it just
your cup is always full
and coming from wholeness is coming from
sourcefulness is coming from
being okay with being nothing and
everything yes
and just pop just try just like pop the
dream for a moment just like be okay
with the dream just disappearing what is
the dream life whatever it is just like
we dream at night yeah we dream at night
we simulate out this like beautiful
complex reality
that
that has
an apparent um observer
uh
that um it does not uh it seems like
there is some sort of differentiation
between the observer and other observers
or the trees or the cars or the roads
and
that goes there there's
apparently the experience of some sort
of senses but you know you just
simulated a dream and so how are there
actually senses
and and and then at after a period of
exploration of some sort
you wake up
and then you wonder
did that happen
so there's just a oneness that's enough
no thingness
undergoing an exploration
and so you just
create an analogy
to the universe to life
and
uh
and there is a very deep recursion
where the the procedure calls on itself
and it makes so much sense where
life
the procedure of the dream
calls on itself at night for eight hours
and it's not always dream sometimes deep
sleep sometimes it's dream
and it's
this is the indescribable perfection
this is pure potentiality this is
nothing being everything and
it's heartwarming
to deplete yourself of
identity and ego and selfishness and
conditioning and all these patterns of
behavior
that create suffering and malevolence
and it's incredible to shift towards
abundance and prosperity and well-being
and oneness and unity
and harmony and sourcefulness in the
field
because
we have our children
and we have also this
incredible since the simultaneity where
yes it's this indescribable perfection
now
right now right here as it is and yet
also there's this yeah we have some kids
and we have an apparent future and it's
cool to also undergo said
inward turn of
what is it that destroys more of the
separation
and what is it that increases the unity
and
yeah
so it's already 100 always whole and yet
it's simultaneously dissolving more and
more of the dreamed illusory separation
love that dude
just such a good back and forth yeah so
good yeah
really fun
really fun
um
the last thing i want to say is
as there are many paths to the mountain
as my
mentor
also said
you don't walk up the mountain you float
because as you let go of things you
become lighter
perfect
and that's the process of enlightenment
enlightenment is not about what we gain
it's about what we let go of
coming back to your analogy of
he said so many good things but
you know you are that black hole of
awareness at the center of your being
and just letting go of all that stuff
that's
floating around because you can do that
yeah you can do that yeah
do you think one last question i would
have for you do you feel like because i
have i know
i have a tendency to believe that
progression or evolution
is
interdependent on or
a
effect of
how much
struggle
or
hardship or
difficulty one
walks through or transcends
do you think that's inherent in the
process of
conscious evolution or growth
or spontaneous
i love that enlightenment
there's so much simultaneity again oh
yeah because the shadow does very
clearly birth fire right and then
there's also
the
apparent
no
shadow somehow birthing right fire right
and
whenever i
um
whenever evolution comes up there's this
that's just the story
it's true that it's also just the story
it's infinity appearing like something
that we call evolution right and
and we cool like we give that a thumbs
up and yet also
you know you're sitting here
promulgating the story of
of
it's just infinity appearing as
evolution and then when some sort of
malevolence
pathology develops within the body and
you go into the western hospital system
to get healed all of a sudden you have
this fear instinct that kicks up am i
going to die am i going to die and then
there's this oh my gosh thank you
western medicine thank you so much for
saving me because you knew about form
and you knew about
pathology and you knew about how to take
it away and so that's also a process of
the appearance of evolution learning
about itself through the analysis of
form to be able to again just merge
together the
the very non-dual it's just an
appearance with the simultaneity of yeah
there's something that we call form and
when we get really good at it we can do
cool things
like we just described yeah
i like that
yeah i have a
i have a
um
one of the core things that we mentioned
throughout was the
analogy of like a black hole
with all of its
stars and planets around it that you can
visualize as your name
like you have these four characters
e-b-e-n and they're just symbols that we
strung together to identify a piece of
life
and your whole game of reality is
basically tied to that first star system
you could say near the black hole
the whole game is pretty much tied to
that
um so if you can make some sort of like
loosening
malleability with that first one of your
i me my which is like this first link
from the black hole
everything else
after that with its likes dislikes and
differences preferences family friends
career all that stuff it more easily
also dissolves
so
so just imagine visualize yourself as a
galaxy and um just use your eye like
look at your [ __ ] eye your eye is the
galaxy you have a black hole called a
pupil right there and you have an iris
around it that is like the stars and the
planets and if you can just look at
someone else's black hole you recognize
that it's that same black wholeness
and then the iris is this unique
differentiatedness
of the costume of the appearance
and
yeah in the ultimate analysis you will
always see a simultaneity you will
always see a oneness and you'll always
see a differentiation in the density of
love-like consciousness simultaneously
yeah which is why you have someone like
eben that's just like
just chill in and then you have someone
else that's like
and so that's your differentiation
but it's also oneness so
it's awesome bro
seriously awesome yeah so fun so good
i'm glad we got this in before you roll
yeah and we'll have a round three at
some point oh definitely potentially
like two of these a year or something
i'd love that yep and just do a little
um it'll be so interesting to see what
is that's like round three what
[Music]
transmitting [ __ ] frequencies
yeah that'll be hilarious oh gosh
awesome dude so good so good yeah thank
you thanks everyone for tuning in
infinite love for you fam thank you
thank you
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode
let us know what resonated what were
some key insights for you
also like the video
helps out that algorithm subscribe to
the channel if you haven't yet also
share the video with other people that
you feel like this would positively
influence create those butterfly effects
check out all of the links in the bio
below
we have
evans youtube page where he's posting
his ebb and flow podcast
he's got a lot of great content on there
that further unpacks what he was sharing
so go and subscribe to his channel check
out some of his content
also it's on itunes that link is below
his instagram his twitter is down there
his recent book that he authored with
augustus a life worth dying for
is also in the bio below you can check
that out
and also his patreon is down there
because eben is independent and so
support him it's just some simple tiers
you know just click on the low tier the
mid tier just click on one of those and
support it's really important that we
keep if you have the ability independent
artist creating content
and
that is all
infinite love as always
love you guys
peace